surveillez votre boîte aux lettres les
premiers envois de déclaration de
revenus 2013 sont partis cette année
encore le dispositif évolu encore plus
de simplification pour les usagers et
également pour nos services la
désignation des usagers change ainsi les
mentions vous et conjoint disparaissent
au profit des neutres déclarant 1 et
déclarant 2 autre nouveauté ce qui opte
pour la déclaration papier n'auront plus
à fournir de pièces justificatives comme
les dons aux œuvres ou les factures pour
IR des crédit d'impôt à condition bien
sûr d'être quelqu'un de bien organisé et
de classer bien ses factures ou ses
documents parce que bien sûr
l'administration a toujours ce droit de
contrôle à postériori et donc le moment
venu si on le lui demande il faudra
qu'il soit en mesure de produivre ces
documents pour ceux qui télédécare le
site impot.gou.fr a été rendu plus
accessible grâce à une connexion par
numéro fiscal et mot de passe et la
création d'un espace
personnalisable ceci permettra à partir
du mois d'août
de choisir d'opter pour une
dématérialisation des avis d'imposition
c'est une première donc avis
d'imposition d'impôt sur le revenu et
également de taxes d'habitation pour nos
résidences principales les ivelines
comptent une population fiscale au
niveau de revenus très diversifiés sur
le territoire près de 735000 foyers
contribuables sur environ 1 million et
demi d'habitants et nous sommes un
département plutôt en pointe en terme de
télédéclaration puisque nous avons 42 %
de nos contribuables qui télédéclare et
89 % qui utilisent un moyen moderne de
paiement lorsqu'ils sont une somme à
payer sur viis d'imposition donc on a 7
à8 points de plus que la moyenne
nationale et on souhaite bien sûr
conserver cet avantage une démarche qui
permet de faire une économie de 850000 €
et de plus de 175 tonnes de papier les
contribuables ivlinois peuvent payer
leur impôt sur le revenu via leur
smartphone et par internet jusqu'au 11
juin minuit pour la déclaration papier
elle est à retourner jusqu'au 27 mai
tout comme l'annexe pour l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune les
contribuables dont le patrimoine net
taxable est supérieur ou égal à 2,57
million d'euros doivent déposer une
déclaration spécifique jusqu'au 17 juin
les centres des finances publiques de
Saint-Quentin plaisir et Manes resteront
ouverts le midi du 13 au 27 mai
précisons que les agents ont reçu pour
consigne de rester dans une démarche
déontologique inutile alors d'espérer
parler avec eux patrimoine des élus ou
compte en Suisse